Ian Gardiner was a much-loved
grandfather husband and brother who died
on Sunday night his family say the 83
year olds final days were spent in a
care home in Kent which was stretched to
the limit his wife Cathy is devastated
to think he died alone without even
being tested for coronavirus as the
disease spread through the care home no
you know what pop did pick up this
puppies piling for you short of staff
because of that they're living on the
shoestring
up and down the country relatives and
care home workers are painting a picture
of a sector which is in places close to
collapse we've been sent this photograph
of staffer to Birmingham care home who
say this is the only protection they
have to deal with residents suspected of
having covin nineteen one care worker
told me she and others are now refusing
to return to work terrified by the lack
of protective equipment they're already
stopped shortages they're already stuff
of self isolating or staff who are off
sick what does that mean for the
residents in the care homes because they
surely can't be getting the level of
care that they need the government
though insists it is listening to
relatives and staff in care homes I'd
say to all those people working in care
homes up and down the country you know
whether it's the people in them whether
it's the people looking after them you
absolutely not been forgotten
some parts of the country are turning to
the military to help resolve the PPE
crisis in Suffolk the Army and the Navy
are delivering equipment from one main
control center which decides who needs
it most
they're concerned about going into
people's homes and providing services so
you know everyone wants PPE but we have
to really be quite strict around what
we're doing getting care homes the
support they need is now a critical
issue with the lives of the most
vulnerable in the community and their
carers at stake Lisa Holland Sky News
Birmingham